this twitch streamer just did the
impossible Dino singail beat
seven soul born games without taking a
single hit let that sink in not a single
hit oh my God guys we did it baby the
so-called God run where he ran through
bloodborne Demon Souls Elden ring sakiro
and Dark Souls 1-3 took Dino 120 days
and 300 tries obviously engaging with
every single encounter in these games
would take for ever so Dino stuck to the
main bosses required to beat the story
let's go baby we're cruising what's even
crazier is the fact that this isn't even
the first time someone's been able to
get through all the soulsborne games
unscathed since Eldon ring came out
there is another absolute Legend a
Spanish streamer Bushido you who got
through the run a few weeks before Dino
still I think we can all agree that what
Dino did was an insane accomplishment